hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000
as always my name is caleb denby and
tonight i'm going to be taking you
through
uh some highlights from daniel dubov's
russian championship that uh just
wrapped up i think a few days ago
i did not watch these games live but as
always i like to click around
on those top level games and
boy oh boy does duboff play some
interesting chess uh he
he always does of course but uh this
tournament especially he seemed to
really
dial it up a little bit and he played
some absolutely stunning games
that i want to to highlight
can i make my voice louder no i can't
but
that background music will have died
away by now so hopefully it's a bit
easier to hear me
i did turn down that intro volume
because i thought it was a little bit
overblown last week but uh hopefully
this all sounds a bit better so as i
said we're talking about daniel duboff
why are we talking about daniel dubois
he didn't even win the russian
championship why are we talking about
this loser of the russian championship
well
he played a really key role in that
russian championship
uh playing spoiler actually defeating
sergey karjakin
we had a good shot to tie yon napomnishi
for first place heading into the final
rounds and
by the way first and second place uh
first place in the russian championship
was yad napomnishi he played a great
tournament
second place sergey karyakin uh the only
person
to defeat yon nimhomnishi was daniel
dubois
and the only people to defeat sergey
karyakin were yon napomnishi
and daniel duboff so clearly this guy is
doing something right
he has the talent that you need to take
down these
world elite players and i i just really
hope he continues to have good results
because
it would be such a pleasure to see more
games like this at the top level
but that's enough talking up duboff
let's take a look at these actual games
and talk about why i wanted to go over
them so do bob starts with e4
e5 we get knight f3 knight c6
and then the slow italian game no roy
lopez
out of dubov perhaps the oldest opening
in chess
uh i think it's the italian maybe it's
the spanish bishop e5 but i think bishop
c4
is a bit older uh and then sergey you
know
is a classical player perhaps one of
those
russian old guard types maybe the last
of that russian old guard types
he likes to defend and so he plays
bishop c5 the joker piano
we continue with the main line now
duboff continues with
c3 and we get knight f6 all very normal
stuff
and here dubov opts for d4 rather than
d3 so d3 would be the the slower way to
go the joko pianissimo
perhaps uh because it's even quieter
than the normal italian
and this is where you get your slow
developing games the type of games you
would expect from the 2018 world
championship
between bobby carawana and magnus
carlson where they both like to play
these slow games and
have you know 80 move long games where
they have plenty of opportunities to
outplay the opponent
but dubov plays things a bit more
interesting with d4
still very well known territory uh
sergey of course captures on d4
and this is where we see do bob going a
little bit crazy
uh okay going just a little bit crazy so
fans of jonathan schrantz will know a
little bit
about some gambits that you can play
from positions like this although i
think
jonathan trance's gambits normally go
with like d4 or something
like something ridiculous like this i
i don't know how to get into those
jonathan trans gambits to be honest
they're all a little bit above my head
so those guys will know a little bit
about gambiting pawns on d4
but you know i i say this to you
jonathan have you seen the move
b4 in this position because this is
a bit of a new one to me of course there
is
a line in the italian where instead of
b4
white does opt for d4 but it does have
sort of a radically different idea than
what we're going to look at here so
just for comparison in this line after
bishop b6
white's idea is not to sort of gain
central control with the move b4
it's just to gain queen side space white
is again going to develop out a little
bit more slowly with d3
keep things compact and try to expand on
the queen side
now that's radically different to what
uh do bob is doing here
uh here he's playing b4 with the hope of
capturing back on d4
and not only doing that just disrupting
the flow
between this bishop and in this king
this is sort of the main point here
and i'm not going to lie to you this
move is is a little bit
above my uh above my head here i don't
think b4 is the greatest move
but that's what makes do bob so so
interesting to watch
we are playing like i said the oldest
opening in chess
and it's move six and i can almost
guarantee you sergey karjakin does does
not have books and books of
or files and files of prep on the move
six before
so only do only duboff would be able to
steer the game in such a crazy direction
uh from from the italian just already on
move six this is sort of what he's known
for
he plays just the the most ridiculous
looking moves out of the opening
and then somehow he manages to make it
work uh that being said this has been
played a few times before but not by
anybody you know of any note at all so
very much a
hidden gem here so sergey continues with
bishop b6 which makes a lot of sense uh
you can compare this with
c takes d4 and then this is probably
what
do bob was hoping to avoid the the move
here is bishop b4 check
and then there's some awkwardness where
we don't have a super comfortable way
to uh get get out of this check knight
c3 puts ourselves
puts us in an awkward pin and bishop d2
is perhaps allowing
a trade as well as interfering with our
queen's access to
two some squares black continues with d5
here and
very well known equality so
uh with b4 duobot manages to avoid those
simplifications
at the cost of weakening a lot of
squares so bishop b6
and now c takes d4 would of course be a
mistake
uh why is that well in the previous
variation it came with tempo on the
bishop it no longer does come with tempo
so black would be happy to just take
this free pawn
that's why we see duba following up with
the move e5 here
first gaining a tempo on the knight
before determining
what to do about this pawn on d4
now in previous games uh players tended
to opt for this move
of d5 and i think this is probably the
best way to just
strictly defuse this this opening before
it ever gets started that being said
i don't know if this actually fights for
the advantage with black which might be
what sergey had in mind
after dewbov had the gall to play b4
against him
so what is the point of d5 well the
point is you really have no option but
to take this knight on f6 if you try
something else like moving this piece
away
it's just going to be a sad story for
you after knight e4 this is going to be
a really strong night
and it's not one that will uh easily be
be pushed away
c takes d4 of course is is always now
going to be hanging
this week b pawn so you really don't
have any choice
uh by the way e takes d6 as well black
is probably just going to castle or even
take the pawn
and uh white's king is just in danger so
all in all white is essentially forced
to take on f6
then black will of course recapture on
the c4 square and from here i think
things are going to simplify a little
bit
white plays b5 to interrupt this defense
of
pawn black can play something like
knight a5
uh and then here at the end of the day
white has a little bit of activity but
black you know gets developed
the king is reasonably safe although it
will not be castling kingside
uh it has a perfectly fine home on the
queen side and black's pieces are
at least participating while it's now
sort of white who's behind on
development so i think d5 is a great way
to defuse the opening but sergey chose a
very interesting move instead
and that movement on the screen now that
move is knight e4
so what's the point of knight e4 well
sergey is attacking a pawn on c3 that
that is the point
uh and now essentially sergey is
highlighting the problem with white's
position
with b4 you gain this weird tempo on the
bishop but now you have to worry about
your b4 pawn for the rest of the game so
again
b4 sort of makes c takes d4 just always
not
not the greatest idea just because it
leaves this b4 pawn in the dust
and it's it's going to be hard to make
up for that it really really is black
would again
be continuing out now with d5 when white
is facing all the same problems as last
time but doesn't even have the bailout
of
capturing on f6 and getting the counter
play with
taking on g7 so black is just
probably winning in this position so we
see dubov come up with the interesting
idea
of bishop d5 instead just sacrificing
the pawn
on c3 as well and going just strictly
for
activity and i don't know if this is
something doubt had
uh in his home cooking still but some i
i think there's only so much you can
prepare in a line like this
and it's really really interesting to
see him go for bishop d5 because
this really is just a sacrifice and
with good play black might just be
better like if you
you know let any sort of engine run here
for a little bit it's it's gonna give
you just minus one it's just gonna say
black has an extra pawn
what are you doing with the white pieces
it's move eight and it's minus one like
how how can you be so silly but duboff
has this
strange power to like believe in these
variations
afterwards and he like keeps going
further and further down these
variations and
you know more often than not when he
plays it over the board you find that
the the evaluation starts to level out
and then practically it starts to tip in
his favor uh quite
often so bishop d5 and black is now
committed after the move knight e4 you
have to be capturing on c3 that was the
whole point
uh white is going to take back here we
see d takes c3
and now the point of duolog's play is
revealed with the move bishop g5
and all of a sudden we have three pieces
developed
black has two pieces developed but is
about to
sort of get all pinned up with the move
knight e7 this is really the only way
to stop the threat to the queen and we
have a very strange looking position now
all right uh ver very very very strange
in fact
black for the moment is up actually two
full pawns
black has lost none of his pawns and
this little e pawn has traveled all the
way
to the square on c3 taking two pawns in
its wake
so the question is
is this good enough for white does white
have compensation
here and again let me reiterate if if
you ask the computer
it says no two pawns is two pawns uh
and black is better but again that's why
do bob is so interesting
he just looks past that and looks at the
chest position and keeps going and going
and going and eventually
things start to turn around so uh duboff
simply castles here
and i think this is really informative
uh a lot of people who want to play
the crazy gambits they get sort of
sucked into making threats
turn after turn after turn uh right you
know bishop g5 threatening looking move
now you want to immediately
somehow attack this knight further but
there simply isn't a good way to do that
and a lot of time a lot of the time most
of the times
uh in these gambits your compensation
doesn't necessarily come
from making immediate threats right do
bob is is not making anything immediate
out of the position
your compensation comes in this case in
the form of extra development
so developing further does nothing to
worsen that compensation
and it also comes in the form of this
extra space
right black's pieces are just awkward
due to this pawn on e5
due to this nice bishop on g5 and that's
not gonna
go away and it's not gonna be improved
by by making continuous threats here so
moves like
queen b3 moves that make one move
threats try to regain material
that's not necessarily what white should
be doing here white is just interested
in completing development and
highlighting the fact that black's
pieces
are horribly misplaced uh now sergey
karjakin
of course has the nickname of the
minister of defense so it is quite bold
to uh to do this against uh sergey of
all people sacrifice these two pawns and
say i'm gonna like checkmate you i'm
gonna
use this act of compensation to to win
the game but
that's why do bob is fearless uh so now
black is sort of left with
this awkward situation here right you
would love to
develop this bishop somehow but this
pawn on e5
is making that difficult you definitely
don't want to allow white
to open the e file and plant a rook
opposite your king
you would love to castle but uh again
rookie one is going to be coming you're
not really solving the issue
of this knight on e7 and so it becomes
sort of this question of
how do you actually untangle here with
black and that's a question
i want to ask uh ask the chat room here
what do you guys think
is is the best way to untangle see if
you can figure it out
see if you can figure this one out here
what's going on
i look like daniel dubov am i do buff i
wish i was do bob
unfortunately i am not so brave
nor so talented
at the game of chess
okay so there's a couple really good
ideas in the chat already so
the problem with d6 that i mentioned is
that after e takes d6
white opens up this e file and is able
to plant a rook opposite the king
and is likely just winning in that case
so the same problems exist for f6
and potentially even in a worse version
here right white's just gonna take this
pawn
rookie one is coming and this is just
disaster so definitely not
f6 but as harry bowman in the chat said
uh h6 is going to be a really good idea
and this is actually what sergey plays
in the game
and after bishop h4 harry's idea in the
chat was actually to push through with
g5 and i quite like this idea
so what's the point of h6g5
you know how does this make any sense
intuitively
you would say that black has the extra
material so black should just be trying
to you know stay
solid not do anything too crazy like h6
g5
and try to consolidate the advantage and
while that
uh does make sense on um you know in
objective sense those words are all sort
of
objectively correct black should try to
consolidate should try to make things
simple
but sometimes the best way to do that is
to to break some of these principles
right so h6 g5 definitely is breaking
opening principles it's not just
developing it's not
getting any extra pieces in the into the
game but still it's
it's somehow going to be correct here so
let's try and understand
why so why is g5 such a good move well
the fact of the matter is uh
much of white's play was against this
knight on e7 pinning down this queen uh
or pinched to this queen on d8 and with
g5 number one
we are in fact breaking that pin number
two
once this bishop moves out of the way we
are actually able to simplify things by
capturing on d5
so in this case we break some principles
by weakening the king's side with h6 g5
but we're following other principles by
getting us closer to
you know sort of pure consolidation by
trading off
some of these minor pieces so really
important to understand
that sometimes counter-intuitive moves
like h6 g5 weakening the king side
can be called for if it directly is
is going to simplify the game and i
think here black's task is
is much much easier white is still going
to have some activity and some
compensation for example queen takes d5
but now black can castle comfortably and
it's not immediately
clear how white is really going to take
advantage of the weaknesses created over
here
and in the meantime black's next move is
going to be d6
the bishop is going to come out to e6
and black will be doing
well so g5 would have been a really
great move to see
uh and i'm sort of surprised that sergey
didn't really go for this
uh i i guess in sergey's mind uh if i
had to guess
um he was just thinking uh i can just
castle king's side here there's no
reason to go
crazy with g5 and weaken things i'm
able to solve all these problems uh in
in the near future but
i think this was just a bit too slow by
sergey and i think that after kingside
castles this is where the game
definitely starts to turn
in duval's favor so really instructive
move here really instructive missed
opportunity
g5 would have been great it super
simplifies
black's defensive task and would have
been i think really good perhaps
something sergey might have missed
is that after knight takes g5 uh black's
uh
path to victories is actually a little
bit narrow here black
should not really be taking on g5 this
is probably something that
many of you are worried about when that
now this pin is going to be essentially
unbreakable
but black has a really nice inner mezzo
here you can just take on d5
and now the knight is pinned to the
bishop so it moves like knight takes f7
96 none of those are going to be working
we just capture on
h4 and the move knight f3 is met by the
move
knight back to e7 this knight escaped
its pin and then had to come back
but now with a bishop to the good uh
black is is just strictly winning
uh okay so g5 would have been really
nice instead though we get
king side castles which is perhaps the
more natural move
but uh it is the move that allows white
to keep some keep some really nice
compensation here
so how do we continue the attack now
with white i'm curious to see
what you guys have in mind here how do
you want to play this position
with the white pieces was g5 almost
winning i i think black would be
uh would would be strictly better after
g5
uh in the objective sense is it winning
i i i don't know that's a difficult
question to ask this early on
but black would be better and more
importantly than that
brac white's practical chances really do
go down
once this knight is traded for this
bishop on d5
right these gambits aren't necessarily
about the objective evaluation and it's
more about
giving yourself an easier time over the
board
practically
so there's some pretty good ideas in
chat uh
manny says knight d4 to f5 this is an
important idea to keep in mind
and this is sort of falling into this
idea of trying to immediately increase
the pressure of the knight on e7
chess king just wants to play bishop b3
and keep the strong two bishops and
bishop b3
is actually a pretty good move here but
it's not necessarily the best move
so i've talked a little bit about where
white's compensation actually is in the
position you can get
sort of different types of compensation
uh
in these sort of crazy gambits and here
as i mentioned white's compensation is
largely coming from the fact that
black's pieces are are sort of
awkwardly placed it's difficult to get
this bishop into the game uh with this
knight pinned on e7 in the strong pawn
on e5
this knight is obviously not able to
move just yet
uh and so do bob's move uh of rookie one
and this is what was played in the game
and it's the best move it is actually
going to be the best here
and this makes a lot of intuitive sense
right at first glance this move looks a
little bit mysterious
why waste time moving the rook from f1
to e1 both these files are closed
anyways
but do bob is playing against his
opponent's pieces that's where the
compensation is in this position
it's playing against black's awkward
pieces
so why rookie won well dubois was
worried that black was going to play d6
and activate this bishop and this move
just strictly prevents that and that's a
really important idea to keep in mind
here
again dewbomb's compensation is not
coming from making immediate threats
which is a really common mistake
when playing crazy openings like this
it's not even coming from the idea of
regaining the material while we have the
time uh it's coming from the idea
of just maintaining the position
maintaining these threats against blacks
pieces making sure they can't untangle
it's a very preventative way to play
and it's correct here so really
important to understand
rookie one uh still more pressure on e7
so so yes
it is adding more pressure to e7 but
it's important to understand
that this is a tool for do bob he's not
trying to win the game
on e7 he's trying to use the threats on
e7
to with the purpose of keeping this
bishop on c8
uh locked in and keeping this knight
locked down as well
right it's important to make these
threats with a purpose not just
play something like knight d4 to f5 and
try to
you know make threats to just win the
game outright
um although okay i should mention
sometimes you can just win the game
outright with these kinds of threats
but you do have to calculate those and
understand that your opponent often has
uh ways out of them so in this case
knight d4 of course is quite bad
in light of g5 once again when now the
bishop is actually just hanging
so rookie one really great move by dubov
uh and sergey very methodical player
plays the move queen e8
he says all right i was pinned now i'm
not
uh and step by step he's trying to to
bring his pieces into the game and
achieve that consolidation
that he so desperately wants and now we
actually are going to get chess king's
move uh chess king in the chat
had suggested bishop b3 and this is
going to be correct here
so again do bob's not in any rush in
this position
he's just trying to play against his
opponent's pieces
and make sure that when the time is
right
he'll be able to strike okay
so now uh sergey karjakin is still sort
of left in this this awkward spot with
bishop b3
dubov is maintaining the strong bishops
maintaining the pressure in the position
uh karjakin still can't really play the
move d6 or d5
for fear of e takes and opening the e
file
and so there's not really a good way to
bring this bishop into the game
so sergey actually does find a really
nice move here
one of the only moves to sort of
maintain the balance in the position
and that move is a5 so sergey is saying
well if i can't activate my bishop maybe
i'll activate my rook
and i think this is the idea with a5
so really nice idea i do want to mention
though
that perhaps knight f5 would have been a
better way to approach this idea of
consolidation again just trading off one
of these bishops
trying to get rid of some of these
pieces making all the threats in the
position
uh you know at the cost of of some extra
time i think this would have been
a good idea here as well computer
grease uh for example there's no
comfortable way to keep this bishop so
white should probably try to
activate the queen and then we can just
take off this guy
and start giving some material back with
something like d5
and queen d7 and black probably isn't
going to be any better in these
positions anymore
but at least you know we've got this
bishop in in the game
right that that was the goal uh okay
but instead of knight f5 we do see a5
and i think this is a good idea
to try and keep an advantage
and now do bob's next move is quite an
impressive one so chat room once again i
want to ask you guys
how to continue the position here how to
continue
why doesn't g5 work now well the point
of g5
was that we could simplify things by
taking the bishop
on d5 so right now g5
would in fact be you know sort of
enticing white to move the bishop away
maybe white can still take on g5 but
even let's say
i'll give you that i have to play bishop
g3 now the point
is not really there right we're no
longer taking off the bishop on d5 we're
no longer really simplifying
d6 and d5 are still still hard to play
and so it does turn out that this
now just is a weakening move played sort
of without purpose
really important to understand why these
moves are being considered
uh it's not necessarily to make a threat
to force a piece away
it's to do things with the purpose for
white the purpose is constricting
black's pieces
for black the purpose is consolidation
simplifying getting pieces off the board
and getting closer to activating the
bishop
okay there's some ideas in the chat to
talk about here
and yeah great wolf has a good question
here
uh whenever you play like this in games
you sort of have an unsettling thought
in the back of your mind that you don't
have enough compensation or that your
position is worse
and i think that's something uh sort of
brought on
by computers and people's obsession with
you know pleasing the computer
evaluation and that's why i want to talk
about do bot
right move six the guy is playing a
position that's minus one with the white
pieces
like this guy does not care what the
computer's initial reaction is
and and i don't think you should either
right duo is beating sergey karyoko and
he's beating yon napomnishi
with uh slightly dubious okay well
against yon he played something very
very
very very different than this but
against sergey he's playing something
very dubious
and it's not important what the computer
is always saying
it's important to understand these
practical ideas how easy
is it to solve these problems for black
if it's not easy to solve the problems
then the gambit is is likely worth
trying or at least investigating
and how easy is it to continue posing
problems to black
in this case white is posing all sorts
of problems seemingly
effortlessly right how do you activate
any of these pieces with black
and it's really not not super clear okay
i should say a5 by the way sorry i was
asking you
to evaluate the position after a5 but i
didn't put it on the board
so try to get away from this thinking of
you know
your your best games are the ones where
the computer is super happy with you
this can be true but oftentimes it's
more about being able to pose
problems to your opponent and being able
to solve your own problems so
what do people in the chat have in mind
here specifically
so b5 had been suggested uh a few times
and i i understand the the sentiment
here right so black is trying to sort of
find activity on the a
file so you might be tempted to play b5
and keep things locked down
uh but unfortunately i i don't think
this is going to be
uh quite quite right here so so why is
that well
black doesn't necessarily need to open
the a file to find activity for example
something like a4
and even rook a5 here and black is
is getting active one way or another
uh and perhaps this position is is still
fine but i think
white can do a little better uh so
how should you approach a position like
this so as i've been talking about you
want to continue
posing problems to your opponent and
ensuring that they can't solve the
problems
that they already have so we have
posed this problem of uh not being able
to
activate this bishop on c8 so we should
be thinking
about ways black can try to
actually activate this bishop what is
black going to try to do to get this
piece in the game
try and untangle this queen from the
back rank and get the knight in the game
well
obviously a few moves sort of come to
mind that black should be thinking about
so not only like a4 like i was saying
but moves like knight g6
moves like knight f5 definitely come to
mind here
right and what's the point well the
point is we're going to take off this
bishop
from g3 continue with d5
and bring our queen off this e file now
our bishop has access into the game
black for the moment is still going to
be a pawn to the good with this pawn
on c3 and uh black has no issues here
black has the bishop pair
open center now the king is safe with
this bishop off the board
and uh yeah white white is just worse uh
objectively and
and practically so that is what we want
to avoid
so how can we avoid such a devastating
fate
well we have to pose some new problems
so how can we pose new problems
okay so yeah uh the the chat room has
some pretty clever ideas now and the
move bishop f6 is
actually going to be uh correct in this
case now bishop f6 doesn't necessarily
win the game but it is a nice way
to continue posing some problems here
right
dubov is cleverly at every moment
making sure this bishop isn't getting
into the game but aside from that
he's looking for new ways to pose
problems as well in this case
problems against the black king so
bishop f6
is yes you know an aggressive looking
attacking move
against this pawn on g7 against this
king
it cannot be captured due to e takes f6
when this pin
is going to be devastating but more than
that it's with the idea of making sure
black cannot simplify things with knight
f5
attacking the bishop on h4 so bishop f6
really great move but it's important to
understand it's not without purpose
right yes it looks like an aggressive
attacking move to attack g7 and things
like that
but at its core it is still a
preventative move it's still preventing
black from simplifying
continuing to pose these problems to
sergey's position
uh okay uh sergey now continues with the
move a4
and this is the the tipping point here
uh after a4
uh dubov is just going to be better
because black
loses the final opportunity to actually
activate this bishop on c8
and break free with the move like d6 or
t5
and it's not so obvious why this is
but let's take a look at the best line
and maybe we can spot the difference
here so
the best way for black to play was
actually with the immediate
knight f5 and then let's say white tries
to activate with the move queen d3
uh now uh black is just going to play
the move d5
protecting this knight on f5 and opening
up this bishop
white of course should take this pawn
but now after queen d7
there's a pin on the d pawn to the queen
on d3
and white would have to settle for
taking this pawn back on c3
because these threats are going to
become very very real pretty
soon then white can simply or black can
simply take on d6
and the problems have sort of been
solved right this bishop is
participating in the game
we got rid of this e5 pawn white has
some scary looking pressure
against the king for now but it's it's
not really amounting to anything
black is going to take on b4 to follow
and
will will be slightly better or at least
uh
at least level at least level in this
position so
what's different with the move a4 well
now
this bishop gets pushed to the c4 square
which does not seem totally relevant
but let's examine that exact same line
now knight f5 for example
queen d3 d5 ed6
queen d7 we have a bit of a problem here
which is now
that white queen white's queen is just
defended
so these ideas aren't going to be as
good uh specifically
due to the tactic of bishop e7 so pretty
deep idea here
but a4 is the move that gives dewbomb
the advantage because of this exact line
where white is able to activate
effectively uh thanks to the queen
on d3 being defended not super easy to
spot you can't really blame him
for missing it but i think this is the
the genius of the way
that that do buff plays i i don't know
if dewbov really fully understood
that a4 was a crucial mistake because of
bishop b7 if you saw this from
from afar but the point is he didn't
really have to
right he played a position where he
could continue posing problems to
black's position
uh more problems than white had in the
position and
sergey eventually cracked right and
white only had to continue
asking these questions posing these
problems and wait for
the mistake by circuit so why does this
win
well if you go rook e8 then knight e5
is trapping a queen and attacking f7 not
ideal
and if you take this guy then i will
take you back
you cannot find the time to take me
because i'll take you with check
and take your queen and queenie eight of
course is also bad
or key8 is also going to be bad bishop
takes f7
and knight e5 is a pretty nasty fork so
fun tactics there for dubai bishop e7
would be winning the game
uh so perhaps sergey koryakin noticed
this
and opted for the better move which is
knight g6 instead of knight f5
unfortunately though this move is not
good enough to
uh to equalize anymore right we still
aren't getting d5 we aren't getting d6
and for those reasons white is just
going to be better
uh dubov now does continue activating
with queen d3
notably this knight on g6 is hanging for
the moment
and karjakin does try this idea of d5
still
but it still isn't going to be good
enough here we see e takes d6
queen d7 would now lose to queen takes
g6 so sergey has to opt for bishop e6
instead
still getting this piece into the game
but it's a little bit too
too little too late uh now dubov
takes on g6 uh and sacrifices his queen
because
of course of course he does right of
course he does uh
i think there are a lot of chess players
on this planet
that would be happy uh playing something
a bit more simple
i think there are a lot of people who
would say all right all right i did
my due diligence i tried my best i'm
going to save all my pieces now
we can trade you can take here it's all
fine oh no
my queen's attacked you can move your
queen i'll take you you take me
i take you you take me i play rook here
we agree to withdraw everybody goes home
happy right i think there are
a lot of people who would be quite happy
to uh to do this but
dubois says you know what you know what
you don't deserve equality yet you don't
deserve equality right i'm ripping open
this diagonal
and taking on e6 so
dubov now has two pieces for the queen
a bishop and knight but of course there
are also an abundance of threats
against this queen uh this king on g8
and this queen on e8
uh immediately uh immediately flowing
uh so uh sergey koryakin tries to move
queen f7
and the the game continues uh from here
so chat how do you want to treat this
position now
how should we continue here
let's see what you think
why not gf instead of queen d7 i think
black's queen was likely hanging
at some point right usually black is
always playing queen d7 because it's
under attack
sacrifice the queen what's the point
well the point is
well i'll talk about the point you tell
me what you think about this position
first
you tell me what you think first
so some people in the chat are falling
for the trick other people
are falling for another trick and as
expected
uh nobody's really coming up with the
move that that duboff played
because it's it's sort of uh sort of
ridiculous right
so everybody says oh god i lost my queen
i gotta take it back i gotta get the
queen back
if i don't then i'll have fewer queens
than my opponent and that's not good
and i you know i re i i i like that
statement right and
generally queen queens are good to have
but the problem is
you look at this position uh yes you got
your queen back
but like now what uh now you're down
a pawn right
we did this brilliant queen sacrifice
and now we have fewer pawns than our
opponent
and like this is a threat and like this
isn't helping things
like that's a scary pawn now and black
is probably just winning
so rookie 4 isn't good enough and then
95 is actually losing
to to the same ideas black just gives
the queen back
we take here king h7 this bishop is
hanging
what do you want to do about it if you
go bishop b7
uh i'll take on f2 and then you're going
to be very very sad
going to be very very sad so duboff says
hey you know my pieces are pretty active
i'll play bishop take c3
and now it's your turn and now it's your
turn you play a move
and i'd like to to lie to you and say
that you can
find moves like bishop takes c3 by it by
following these attacking principles
right we want to pose problems to black
we want to
you know do all this but that that sort
of isn't
entirely true i think here do bob just
calculated everything out calculated
rookie 4 calculated
you know 95 calculated the other options
calculated bishop takes c3
and he said ah i calculated bishop takes
c3
is correct and the unfortunate truth of
chess is that it
is going to be a game of specifics at
the end of the day
so general principles aren't going to be
enough to guide you through everything
so
bishop takes c3 is a pretty brilliant
move just
saving the peace renewing the threat of
rookie 4
and pinning the the queen to the king
again 95 is
is still something to consider as well
in many positions
but at the end of the day if you're
going to play crazy lines like this
you have to be ready to to do the work
over the port you have to be ready to
calculate out the lines
and you have to trust yourself in those
calculations so
that can be really tough uh which is why
uh you know everybody
and their grandmother tells everybody
else hey the way to get better
is do tactics and the reason for that
isn't necessarily
because you know tactics are the the
end-all be-all
but positions like this you feel more
comfortable going for
uh if you believe it to be the best way
forward than
if it really is necessary that you're
able to trust yourself
trust your calculating ability uh and
play moves like bishop takes c3
when when you think it's called for uh
okay
so bishop takes c3 played in the game uh
now the question is for black
it's your turn what do you do um
sergey i think plays the most natural
move which is king h8 right
bishop pins queen to king move king away
uh queen no longer pinned
i have four queens gg uh dubov now
continues with the tactical line of
rookie four
uh renewing the threat against the queen
sergey opps
for queen f5 just removing the queen
from the threat of capture which is
always good
and now do bob's point is revealed after
the move rook
e7 uh which is uh pretty crazy so
rookie for attacking the queen with the
point that the queen now has to leave
uh it's attack of the bishop on c4
and dubov can just increase the pressure
against this king
now threatening bishop takes g7 with uh
checkmate to follow
uh and yeah black just has no good way
to to stop this
and that's that's the the long and short
of it here uh sergey plays rick g8 in
the game
but now white is going to actually take
this material
take on c7 and now uh the material
account for those of you who lost track
is a knight and a rook for a queen but
white now has this nice pawn
on c7 uh sort of sort of debut and that
pawn's actually not going to be dying
anytime soon
so white is is simply winning here right
yes because of the pawn on c7 but also
because you know black's pieces are
are yet again completely tied down to
the defense of
the king at this point uh well
specifically this rook is tied down
these pieces not so much but that's
where this pawn on c7 comes into play
as well it's just too hard to keep track
of everything with
these few pieces left alright so
queen c2 played in the game and this is
a good move
trying to attack this pawn on c7 as well
as the pawn on the f2
but dubois isn't worried about losing f2
what matters is this pawn on c7 so
bishop e5 in the game
bishop takes f2 played king h1
bishop back to b6 was karjakin's choice
and it's sort of hard to suggest any
improvements at this point
uh you can't really make any threats
against this king this knight is a great
defender this bishop also defends the
king's side as well
the rook defends the first rank and it's
connected to this bishop as well
really great harmony with white's pieces
here this rook is of course
completely immobilized and so like what
do you do
there's not much to do so bishop b6
played and
keeping in mind this fact that this
bishop can't really do anything useful
this rook can't really move my king is
entirely safe
uh duval just does the main thing here
which is
plays h3 says yeah
you know i just want to eliminate the
threat of any backrank mates and i'll
just improve my position slowly
so sergey plays king h7 stepping out of
one pin
uh but just really exchanging it for
another uh now we see rookie one by
dubov just bringing the rook
into the game again he's in no rush at
this point black is completely tied down
black chooses a3 and this is how black
is trying to find play now
notably queen takes a2 would be a bit of
a mistake for multiple reasons
but perhaps the the easiest way to
understand it
is just the move rook c1 when now
there's no way to stop
c8 queen
also by the way this queen is in fact
serving an important role here i
should mention if it leaves to go to a2
then uh we can actually play rook takes
g7
as well with ca queen okay so multiple
reasons why queen a2 isn't good
so black plays a3 which is essentially
passing uh
duboff plays king h2 improving the
king's position
um black plays g5 and now finally
uh the the the final blows uh do
do start to come here so we have two
pieces attacking
g7 and dubov decided hey
wouldn't be nice if wouldn't it be nice
if i attacked that
guy a third time and that's what he goes
for now with
with uh knight to d4 just heading to f5
and trying to win the game
karjakin could exchange this bishop for
this knight but this isn't really going
to help things too much
uh the position is is still sort of just
completely hopeless like let's say
uh white pass black passes here which is
going to go rook d7 and go over e7
we're going to take on g7 and we're
going to win the game
uh okay uh sergey tries queen c4
immediately instead
but now knight f5 was the point and it
is still a good point
uh black tries queen takes b4 but now we
have
rook c1 as i said the queen needed to
stay on the c file to stop the c8 ideas
king g6 played in the game but now rick
takes g7
uh king takes on f5 or takes on g8 takes
on c7 takes on c7
and white now has two rooks and a bishop
for
the queen and this is just gonna be a
winning advantage uh in fact more than
that
black is getting checkmated rather
immediately here so
queen b2 played in the game we have rook
c5 check king e4
rook d8 and here black
black simply resigned sergey had seen
enough and
was ready to throw in tau specifically
because again checkmate is coming
quite quickly here quite quickly
uh okay so that's how you beat sergey
karjakin uh
easier said than done of course easier
said than done
and this is why i think dubov is is the
most exciting player
to watch sort of bar not at this point
uh
he takes on these these super macho guys
like sergey karjakin like
and he does so rather fearlessly uh with
uh
you know openings like this minus one by
move six
and you know plus a billion by by move
38
pretty good stuff so questions on this
game
and then uh i'll go back and review a
little bit
this game was indeed amazing i tend to
agree and it's as i mentioned at the top
of the hour here it is a really uh
important game for the russian
championship standings duboff sort of
played spoiler this event
um beating both uh first and second
place but beating sergey karakin i think
in the
penultimate round when karjakin had
uh pretty good chances to uh to catch up
to yon
how do you play like this uh well
i think the the key takeaway here is
this idea
of posing problems to your opponent it's
not necessarily
making direct threats dubag made very
few
like actually direct threats here it was
all about playing
this constricting game continuing to
make sergey's position
awkward and make it so that you know he
really had no good options no good moves
to choose from
more so than immediate threats that
needed to be dealt with
uh okay manny had a specific question
though when the queen was on f7 and king
was on g8 why not rookie seven so
in most case it's because this is uh
most cases it was because
this uh bishop was attacked although i
guess your point is that you're taking
here
i think that's just good for
oh well sorry so if here then i think
this would only be good enough for a
draw
uh you can sort of win the queen back
but um yeah don't know if white's gonna
win this game
but worse than that is again the simple
idea of giving the queen back
is still going to be good enough in this
position
as as well good question though that was
one line
that i did not think about
do i like the style of play i like
watching this style of play i don't know
i i'd like to be able to play like this
but i i don't know if i have the the
wherewithal for it to be entirely honest
with you
but let's review how we got here now
that we know how the game transpired so
move six
we have this idea of b4 right
just a move to get serie a out of theory
to avoid these bishop b4 check lines
that happen after c takes d4 right so we
get bishop back to b6
now e5 and i'm sure this was prepped by
dubov
knight e4 not the main idea usually
players go d5 to try to simplify things
and then from here bishop d5 is just
strictly uh
upon sacrifice making uh
making black move this knight again and
loosening black's grip
over the the center and over these key
dark squares
so we get these knights traded off
bishop g5 97
and so with that sort of opening
uh battle nearly out of the way i guess
you could still call this an opening
you could also sort of say black never
finished the opening because the bishop
never got developed
but some this position i found to be
really really instructive
from this game because what does doobab
do
he develops he continues to make his
opponent's position awkward
and he doesn't get bogged down trying to
make immediate threats moves like queen
b3
moves that make a one move threat but
but aren't really useful to the position
black is just going to castle anyways
right
moves like rook c1 trying to take the
pawn back the pawn doesn't matter
the position is about this problem this
dynamic that black has with developing
and white's ability to to keep the
position under wraps so we got castles
h6
sergey missed perhaps an opportunity to
simplify things immediately
g5 with the idea of taking on d5 would
have been good
and then from here rookie one really
really key move
we have to stop black from developing at
all costs we have to keep these pieces
restricted
and to do that we have to make d6 a bad
move
and that's really really important can't
stress rookie one enough
then bishop b3 showing some patience
avoiding simplifications
and then after a5 bishop f6 again
avoiding knight f5 and knight takes h4
ideas
not necessarily trying to checkmate
black immediately
yes we're increasing the pressure there
but first and foremost preventing
the simplifications preventing the
consolidation from black
is priority number one then from here
sergey slipped up with a4 because of
this
very specific tactical line which again
it's just all about calculations
it's about specifics and then from here
uh the rest is is history we have the
glorious queen sacrifice bishop takes c3
and from here the pressure on the king's
side and the pressure with the pawn on
c7
is just enough to win for white okay
really great game here uh such a great
game that i took a little bit too long
on it and we don't have much time left
but i did want to look at at least one
more game here
by duboff and we might have to do it
rather quickly
as we are a bit short on time but i
wanted to see
duval's game against andre esapenko so
for those of you who don't know
astapenko i think
if my numbers are right is sort of the
youngest of this new wave
of russian players dubov i think is only
like 24 25 or something like that but
essepenko is
the youngster teenager at the age of 18.
so essepenko definitely another young
talent that you want to keep an eye on
for the future of russian chess
but for the moment dubov is a bit higher
rated and
perhaps a bit more creative even so
let's take a look
d4 knight f6 c4 e6 knight f3 d5 so
this time we're not getting any crazy
nuances in or
not nuances crazy novelties in the
italian we're getting
a qgd uh we get g3 and it is now going
to be a catalan
bishop e7 bishop p2 castles and queen c2
um so just pretty normal catalan stuff
so far
queen c2 is not the most common
generally white players
castle first uh and only play queen c2
after d takes c4 or
you know continue in the closed catalan
but queen c2 ensures
that the the catalan is going to be
closed so what's the downside to this
move well
the king gets left in the center and
black can take advantage of this with
the move c5 immediately
ripping things open while white remains
uncastled
uh duboff continues with d take c5 which
is pretty mainline stuff
and then generally here players with the
black pieces again take advantage of
this king's position and play queen a5
check
knight c3 and then take on on c4 and
they they get some activity here they
look to recapture their pawn
uh usually with the with the queen i
think
or just develop with knight c6 but queen
takes c5 for example
and black looks to uh clarify things in
the center right away
and just try and get developed white's
gonna have some of this pressure
that you can come to expect from the
catalan but nothing too crazy
and here it's actually essepenko who
deviates from the norm
and plays the move d4 so in this case
uh essepenko is saying you should not
have spent time on queen c2 i never had
any intention of taking your pawn on c4
now that you've committed to this i'm
going to take advantage of the fact that
your queen has vacated the d
file to play the move d4 take away the
c3 square from your knight
hamper your pawn on e2 just a little bit
and take some of this extra central
space
a pretty interesting idea so duboff
continues in sort of the most combative
way it's possible for white to just
castle here but duboff plays the move b4
uh the point now being hey you didn't
take my pawn when you had the chance i'm
gonna defend it now
uh black should play the move a5 to try
and play against this idea
and now do bob gives up on the b4 pawn
but sort of similarly to how black is
taking away the c3 square
white aims to take away the c6 square
and in uh
increase this bishop's pressure over the
light square diagonal here
making use of these c4 and b5 pawns
they work very well in tandem okay all
of that is to say
after bishop takes c5 knight b to d2
knight b
to d7 we are in for an interesting
imbalanced
game so in this case we don't quite have
the crazy sacrificial opening that we
saw
against karjakin but we do have a very
imbalanced opening
so let's take a look at how do love
handles it so
black has this pawn on on d4 and the
question now is going to be
is this pawn uh black's greatest
strength or is it the greatest
weakness and as always the answer tends
to be
both when you have a very far advanced
central pawn
what is what do i mean by that well i
mean this pawn is great it takes
away all these squares from your
opponent and gives you all this nice
central space behind it
but it runs the risk of being
overextended and falling victim
to uh being captured just by virtue of
being in the enemy territory
so do buff of course just increases the
pressure on this d4 pawn with knight to
b3
and here we see essepenko already making
some slight mistakes
according to the computer uh apparently
you had to play the move e5 here
and this makes some some logical sense
right uh black should be ready
to sacrifice some uh material in order
to keep this pawn here on d4 for example
knight c5 knight c5
knight e5 and keeping in line with
black's play
we take advantage of the fact that this
king remains uncastled
and play for counter play down this e
file uh making sure this pawn remains
relevant with threats
of d3 in many positions uh and just
playing actively here
but uh sepenko perhaps not ready to
sacrifice a pawn goes bishop before
check instead
but now white is able to finish
development and maintain a lot of this
pressure with bishop d2
as panko captures on d2 we see knight
f takes d2 the idea of opening up this
bishop
on this diagonal if i could draw the
arrow and now
a4 is the move by acepenko
and this move is perhaps just a little
bit flawed giving up the pawn on d4
and looking at the clock we really are
running out of time
so i do want to mention again maybe the
move e5 was called for here
just uh solidifying this a little bit
but the danger now becomes that after a4
uh
it's going to turn into a one-sided game
here what do i mean by that
well for the moment these pawns are
restricted right e4 is covered plenty of
times
by white's pieces d4 is definitely not
going to move
to d3 at that juncture so black is sort
of left
without a a distinct plan here in the
meantime
white's going to push c5 potentially
push c6
and try to win the game on the queen's
side so this
sort of position where white has a very
clean plan and black sort of does not
can very easily just turn into a game
where black gets
gets run over so perhaps hoping to avoid
this
uh esopenko plays this move a4 but now
uh
dubov is quite happy to take this pawn
on d4 and just be a pawn up
we see the game continue now with e5 and
knight f5 now knight c5
and knight back to e3 so a little bit of
fancy footwork there
all in an effort to solidify things and
increase control over d5
okay we get e4 kingside castles queen d4
so black's pieces are for the moment
active uh but now we see this move
knight d5 another really great move by
doobot again when you are the side with
the extra material your goal
is to consolidate things and sort of
solve the problems that your opponent is
posing to you so here
white's problems revolve around
activating this knight on d2
so for the moment this knight is
completely immobilized right
go to b1 but it doesn't really want to
right so with knight d5
dubov is simply highlighting the fact
that this knight can be active
by attacking this pawn on d on e4
and solving these problems at the cost
of the c pawn so knight takes
on d5 and c takes on d5 played in the
game
and now it's quite clear to see that
this knight is in fact
going to be activated uh estepenko
chooses this move e3 in the game which i
think is
is correct here uh you just simply can't
allow white to be capturing this pawn on
e4
and activating the pieces but now we see
knight c4
instead right the c pawn moving to d5
turns out to be
a blessing with this knight now gaining
an extra square
and so with this what we have is uh
dubov
solving problems that circuitry i can
sort of could not of course these are
very very different positions
but this idea sort of holds true where
when you have the extra material you
just want to consolidate and activate
your pieces
and do i was able to do that with this
move knight d5 whereas sergey was unable
to play the move d5 in the previous game
and that's why we see sort of a
different result out of these openings
okay e takes f2 played in the game and
now
uh it king h1 so knight d5
does turn out to be sort of a true pawn
sacrifice here
by dubop of course it's just sacrificing
back upon
that black sacrificed earlier on d4 but
it is
giving material back but what's really
important here isn't the material
it's that white managed to get active
and still has a very strong pawn
on d5 uh black continues now with bishop
d7 but rick ad1 is kicking black's
pieces around
we see queen d6 d6
rook a to e8 and this pawn is is simply
too strong
knight b6 now is making threats over
here and after rookie 5
this is why i wanted to go over this
game so badly
because it shows that dubai is just
insane he's just not not a sane human
being i can't phrase it any other way
there are a ton of really good moves
here for white white can play almost
anything and be substantially better
maybe winning
in fact but i want to ask the chat room
what you would play in this position and
what you think dubock played
in this position take a second here why
not rook f2
um there was a rook on a1 hanging in the
position
there's a rook on a1 sorry
seems like i'm drinking a fine red wine
just coca-cola just drinking soda
because i like sweet things like a child
just soda
so everybody wants to play bishop takes
b7 but i'm not so sure that this tactic
actually works
i'm not so sure this tactic actually
works
you might get might get tempo'd here
with bishop f5
um so knight takes d7 i think is the
natural move
that a lot of people would want to play
you take off this blockading piece
you take on b7 and you just you have a
good chest position
right you just have a great position
here the knight on d7 is yes a good
block hater
but you know it's it's not really doing
anything compared to this bishop on f3
which controls
huge swaths of the board where it's
going to be able to take this pawn back
on f2 a4 is also weak d6
is not going anywhere and white is is
simply winning
um but dubois of course says
i haven't sacrificed anything this game
i i gotta play queen takes c5 which is
just
oh my goodness um and as always
uh chess is a game of specifics as i've
said
earlier tonight and so i i think he just
did the calculations here he just said
yeah
i calculated queen take c5 because uh my
name is dubov
and that's what i do i calculate the
queen sacrifice
and it's winning so you went ahead and
played it
uh rook takes c5 of course must be
played and now this
uh bishop has no defenders this was the
point
the queen's attacked so queen g5 should
be played to defend the rook
and now simply knight takes f8 king
takes that fate
and d7 and dubois point is that you have
no way to stop me from queening
aside from queen to d8 and this is not
going to be good enough
after rook takes f2 white is just going
to activate
and make use of the fact that in a sense
white is just up a piece
right uh it's two pieces for a queen but
sometimes
two pieces just can do more than one and
we see
that sort of in full effect here after
rook c7
and bishop h3 in a sense this bishop is
fully neutralizing this rook and this
rook is fully neutralizing
this queen what do i mean by that these
two pieces only purpose
is to stop the d7 pawn and attack it the
only purpose of these two pieces is to
support the d7 pawn
and that leaves white with an extra rook
on f2
and for that reason white is simply
winning in this position
g6 was played and dubov is very very
mean so he plays the mover of f6
saying take my rook i dare you uh of
course
black cannot do to queens so we see king
g8 and rook f
d6 rook c2 rook 6 to d2
willing to trade off the rook rook c7
or d3 now f5 b6
rook c2 and now the last move of the
game
rook e3 when essie penko uh
throws in the towel here just just
resigns rookie 8 is coming
and it cannot really be stopped and
duboff
wins again so there was a lot
to uh to take away from from this game
um in in the game before it but
mainly i i just really wanted to
highlight these these really crazy games
that that dulov played uh in this
russian championship
he didn't end up winning but i'm sure
it's only a matter of time before he
does take home
uh the title uh for himself
so hopefully you you learn something
from today's lecture the the key points
that i really want to hammer home here
are this idea of treating gambits
differently right you don't
play a gambit in order to make immediate
threats right away you don't try to
immediately win the game
with your gambit out of the opening the
the more important thing
is to pose problems to your opponent in
the games today
the problems were related to developing
uh doobab did not
allow karyakin to develop his pieces and
get into the game
and in the meantime uh dubob was able to
do just that against scpenko
and then used that advantage to
sacrifice the queen and win in glorious
fashion
so hopefully you guys really enjoyed
this lecture
uh i had a really great time analyzing
these games beforehand
and just uh admiring the the
fearlessness that dubov has right this
guy just cannot stop sacrificing his
queen
uh if you're watching live please stick
around we're gonna have the end game
class right after this
uh just click on the youtube channel it
should already be there scheduled
if you're watching the youtube version
or you or if you've just had enough
chess for tonight i wanna thank you
again for watching
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will see you next time
ah i'm still here oh no i didn't mean it
you